generative AI app builder allows you to
create applications focused around
search and chat experiences with minimal
coding required first you go to the
generative AI app builder section in the
Google Cloud console
then you enable the API
then you select create a search engine
then you give it a name and choose the
data type after our search engine has
been created we just need to add the
sites we want to include after setting
the website we now have a view of the
URLs included in our search engine you
can also add more websites if you want
and just that fast the search engine has
already indexed our website Enterprise
search gives you an out of the box
developer experience whether it's web
pages tabular data or documents like PDF
files you can just bring them in if
you're super excited to get started go
to The Trusted testers page on the
Google Cloud website to apply for Early
Access